Speaker 1: Hey, I have a very I don't want
to spend a lot of time on this. We've had
so much stuff on the program already. There's
a video that came out of a very disoriented,
visibly confused Donald Trump at Mar a Lago with
Charlie Kirk standing next to him. It's a bizarre
video where Trump says people were trying
to vote for Kerry Lake in Arizona in miles,
in five miles long lines and for 10 hours on
Election Day. Now, that happens to be a lie.
But let's listen to what he said. The audio's not
great, but let's do our best to figure it out.
Speaker 3: Here lies in a
three, four, five miles long.
Speaker 1: Three, four, five mile long lines.
Speaker 3: For hours on. And the voting machines
were broken.
Speaker 1:
And remember, there were a few tabulators that
briefly didn't work.
Speaker 3: For the
recount, and there was only one brought in
using force, and there were more of them.
And thousands of people left that line. Yeah.
They had to go home to they're simply going to
have to go through in order or maybe not, who
is going to be able to stand in the Arizona
sunshine? Right now it is 85. As a general
rule, they were right was an essential service.
Speaker 1: Folks. The line went to outer
space. Some people are still in line today,
a month later. There is no hyperbole to
absurd for Donald Trump. And, you know,
if this stuff was true, which it's not. If
there was only something that could be done
to help those voters where it's hot and
they're elderly and they don't feel well,
something like where maybe they could fill out
a ballot and then take it to the post office or
maybe leave it in their mailbox vertically to
be picked up by the U.S. Poster Postal Service.
Or maybe if there were more locations to vote, or
maybe if there was early voting at several hundred
locations where people could go and it would
spread out the crowds if this stuff were true.
It would be nice if there were something that
we could actually do about it. Now, of course,
we all have to ask ourselves, where was the news
coverage of five, five mile long lines, five mile
lines to vote, even four mile lines or three mile
lines. Trump said it was three or four or five. If
there was a three, do you realize if there was
a single line that went three miles to vote?
It would have been national news all day on
November 8th. And they the only story was
some lines. And a few malfunctioning tabulators.
It really makes you think. Here's, by the way,
just another video of the scene at Mar a Lago.
Seems absolutely bizarre. Here is Trump, I guess,
looking for Michael Flynn in a crowd around
the same time that he gave that strange rant.
Speaker 3: I learned a lot of commotion down
here as I wrote a hell of a really good.
Speaker 1: By the way, this is Trump at a
meet at some event of filled with conspiracy
theorists down there at Mar a Lago.
Speaker 3: And everything I said when I.
Speaker 1: Heard the food's going to be.
Speaker 3: Good, throw the 80 blues,
you have to agree. But it's great to have you
know, General Flynn is one of my favorites.
He's a great gentleman. A great man has
gone through hell. Yeah. And he's got.
Speaker 1: Michael Flynn and other
conspiracy theorists apparently. Were there.
Speaker 3: Regulars? There are so of the things.
Very, very good. Ten years ago there was no no.
What's going on? Where is he, by the way? Who
is it? Well, I'm general you know, the general
guy. And do you guys worry that you're a much
more handsome man? You know, you're all right.
Speaker 1: It's gotten very sad. Trump's the
deejay, Trump's the maitre d, Trump's the guy
who comes through saying, is there? Is there
a Flynn here? Is there Michael Flynn here?
It's all getting wacky. There were no ten
hour waits. There were no five mile lines.